i'm back again to talk about the number
one backyard weed
that has the potential
to replace all of your medications and
that's pretty cool but of course check
with your doctor before
taking any of this advice okay this is
just food for thought for you to do your
own research which is a very very
powerful
pesky herb growing in your backyard
right now
that
can greatly benefit you even if you're
not on medications and no it's not
marijuana okay the first benefit is it
can act as a potent
diuretic okay that means it gets rid of
fluid retention edema in your ankles and
your feet it can help you get rid of
that now that is going to help you
reduce blood pressure okay now there's
another effect on blood pressure
it's loaded with potassium you have to
realize that when someone is deficient
in potassium their blood pressure
naturally goes up okay because potassium
is a physiological relaxer of the
vascular
system and
when you don't have enough potassium you
have all sorts of issues with the heart
including blood pressure so this weed is
loaded with potassium and many other
minerals especially like magnesium
next benefit is it can help reduce
insulin resistance which is behind i
would say 70 75
of
health problems out there and that means
it can get rid of the fat off your liver
it means that you can help stabilize
your blood sugars it can help your blood
pressure from a different angle because
too much
insulin from insulin resistance makes
your arteries stiff and hardened
also having too much insulin can create
boils on the back of your knee so if you
have boils or a baker's cyst you can say
goodbye to them if you consume this weed
now the other interesting and surprising
benefit of this weed is it has the
potential to
reduce the reproduction of a virus
hiv virus okay so it slows down the
reproduction of that virus this weed can
also prevent fibrosis in your liver so
if you have a fatty liver if you have an
inflamed liver that's heading towards
cirrhosis which is scar tissue consuming
this weed can slow down that process all
right the next benefit and i'm going to
explain what five alpha reductase
inhibitor is but
this weed can help reduce this right
here which then can reduce dht
thereby
helping you with preventing hair loss
like alopecia as well as shrink an
enlarged prostate okay
now if a female has too much dht she
could have facial hair
she could also have hair loss so it can
it could work in men and women this weed
and i'm going to reveal that very soon
also acts as an aromatase inhibitor now
what is that it's another blocker of an
enzyme
that helps lower
excessive amount of estrogen so
if you're a male that has man boobs or
you're losing
hair on your lower legs or you're just
your voice is going higher or whatever
it can help regulate that it also works
in women that have too much estrogen
estrogen dominance so it helps regulate
estrogen
and this week can help stimulate bile
which can then
help with bloating
preventing gall stones
helping with constipation
and a lot more digestive issues okay now
what is this herb
dandelion greens okay not just the
greens the whole dandelion you can eat
the roots you can roast them and make
coffee out of it an alternative type of
coffee which is actually tastes very
similar to coffee
the greens which are very bitter you put
some of those in your salad
you want to probably offset these bitter
greens with other types of leaves
because it's very very bitter and it's
kind of tough but it's very therapeutic
to include in your daily salads and you
can eat the little flowers the yellow
flowers and you can put those in your
salad or make a tea out of it i'll put
some recipes down below
what's interesting
about
this weed that everyone's trying to kill
is that it's
designed to survive all sorts of
conditions
and because of that it's
created
very powerful
natural chemical compounds that you can
use for your own health in fact
that weed is way healthier than probably
most of the vegetables that you're
consuming and also its roots can go way
way down into the earth you know like 20
25 30 feet and grab these minerals and
pull them up
so
if the superficial topsoil doesn't have
the minerals
it will go down and pull the minerals up
there so when you're consuming
dandelion greens you're getting a lot
more nutrition than most
vegetables that don't dig their roots
that deep now dandelions have been
around for a very long time the romans
consumed them the egyptians the chinese
a lot of different cultures
even in india
use dandelion tea for a lot of different
ailments but you should be aware that
these dandelions are growing right in
your backyard of course don't consume
them if they've been sprayed with
pesticides clean them very well i
recommend even growing them in your
garden and that way you'll have enough
to consume on a regular basis deadline
greens are one of the best things for
your liver
after milk thistle okay
since so many health problems stem from
your liver it's a very very good thing
to include in your diet now if you
haven't seen my video on milk thistle
you should probably watch that next
check it out